cette non non mademoiselle mademoiselle
excusez-moi de vous aborder aussi aussi
cavalièrement mais enfin on est là tous
les deux tout seul sur ce banc public
dans ce grand square dr ça fait quand
même un bon moment et puis je dis rien
du tout alors qu 'on va normalement pas
tirer un homme et une femme tout seul
sur un banc comme ça dans un jardin
public
surtout si ton type arrive la fille est
déjà là tout cela depuis un moment
enfin normalement le type drague la
fille et moi pas même et vous m'en
voulez pas si je veux si je vous drague
pas je peux je peux continuer à
bouquiner
non je vous dis ça parce que draguer on
est de toute façon on cache pas les
pitots tu l'auras dorment tous non mais
vous vous faites ce que vous voulez on
est en république
oui non mais justement draguer ya quand
même pas que ça dans la vie je suis pas
je vois moi il ya des couches drague et
puis il ya des couches drague pas un
puits là c'est là c'est un coup je
bouquine voilà je voulais simplement
parce que je voudrais pas que vous n'en
vouliez vous que où que vous preniez
pour enfin pour un type pas normal que
désirez-vous j'ai pas tirer de
conclusion je me suis simplement dit
tiens encore un parano schizo primaire
qui fait un blocage agoraphobe inhibit
if rapport au plan du niveau du square
si c'est tout alors là non
non je ne suis pas par un niveau machin
je suis pas inhibé moi j'suis pas inhibé
puisque je vous adresse la parole un bon
et si je vous adresse la parole c'est
simplement parce que parce que je suis
poli que je tiens à mettre les choses au
point
dragué ça m'emmerde je vous trouve pas
spécialement tard non mais dites dans
médite dont je vous demande rien hein
c'est pas parce que j'ai mis une jupe
fendue mon balconnet double juliette un
porte jarretelles noir et puis un petit
trip ou des fripons en dentelle incrusté
comme il faut maintenant qu'il faut tout
de suite de vous imaginer des trucs
malades anomalies dans lequel imagine
rien du tout moi non mais entendons-nous
bien à moi je n'ai rien d'autre à vous
personnellement
seulement maintenant avec les moeurs
d'aujourd'hui si on vous voit tout de
suite la main en aucune façon un [ __ ]
lors de m ouais ouais
photo code automatique vous voulez qu'on
fasse pas chez toi moi j'écoutais en
tout cas toute façon vous faites ce que
vous voulez et puis avec qui vous voulez
et quand vous voulez mais tant
république en tout cas vous êtes
sûrement mal dans votre peau ans
si vous manque une vie c'est pas mon
problème façon je m'en fous je réponds
même plus je m'en vais de type quoi tu
pas votre type 1 si si c'est tout à fait
vrai nom voici vous dit ça comme ça
c'est que je suis pauvre type
on ne me la fait pas c'est quand même
nous les femmes qui avait l'intuition
féminine
ou alors si je réponds ça va faire mal
et c'est quoi votre bouquin on peut
savoir un autre bouquin tiens voilà une
question intéressante
non mais ça ça c'est intéressant c'est
un boulot fantastique ça s'appelle la
faune hétérosexuels dans nos régions nos
frappes on n'en sort pas mais non ne
sait pas que son service sur la vie des
animaux enfin moi fois quand même fait
un effort d'imagination
tiens y'a qu'à prendre l'arbre qu'il a
le grand tarbes qui l'a dit la petite
branche verte qu'elle a un bon alors
c'est printemps un bon alors c'est le
printemps bon il ya une pige jeunes qui
se pointe un vrai se pose sur la branche
bon pied alors évidemment comme c'est le
printemps l'api jaune sans tout drôle
un bon là dessus il ya pigeons qui
arrive alors automatiquement la pige on
n en peut plus et ça roucoule normal non
non justement ça roule pas forcément
parce que figurez vous que le pigeon lui
la tête d'autres choses à faire voilà le
pigeon lui il peut réfléchir à des
machins ou alors il est branché sur les
moineaux ou alors c'est pas moi qui
gamberge sur l'environnement ou alors il
va bouquin vachement intéressant qu'il a
envie de lire peinard tout seul sur son
banc sans personne pour emmerder voilà
messi mais c'est pas grave mais ça me
gêne pas du tout que vous lisiez et tout
ça il sera bon ou comme un imbécile un
livre à la consoude caf pour rien dans
le pantalon
vous faites ce que vous voulez on est en
république
c'est un comble alors déjà déjà qu'on
n'a pas les salaires égaux qui nous font
d'électricité maintenant des bombes
atomiques qu'avec 100 francs n'a rien en
tout 50
sans compter tous les viols de sacs à
main alors si en plus de tout en plus de
tout si encore à nous les femmes à
draguer les hommes
votre groupe
[Applaudissements]
c'est non non
[Musique]